en este vídeo quiero que pensemos un
poquito que necesitamos para construir o
fabricar cosas para estimular un poquito
la imaginación aquí puse dos dibujos
aquí a la izquierda parece ser que es
una herrería y hay unos cuates
trabajando con el fuego y haciéndonos
espadas o escudos o algo así y de este
lado tenemos una fábrica de aviones
entonces ahí están los aviones hechos
pues construyendo ese poquito a poquito
salen pero bueno en general que
necesitamos para hacer cosas ahí hay
varios elementos verdad
por un lado necesitamos un terreno un
terreno un terreno por ejemplo esta
fábrica de acá necesita estar situada en
algún lugar esta realidad también
entonces necesitamos ubicarlas en algún
lugar por eso necesitamos un cierto
terreno además necesitamos un edificio
edificio bueno a lo mejor no pero en la
mayoría de los casos necesitamos un
edificio necesitamos herramientas de
trabajo herramientas ya sabes todo el
equipo herramientas le va a poner aquí
equipo acá los martillos de este lado
tuercas cosas por el estilo además
necesitamos algo para que realmente la
fábrica corra verdad por ejemplo acá
necesitamos electricidad no necesitamos
a lo mejor petróleo o aceite gasolina de
este lado necesitamos el fuego y
necesitamos los elementos básicos
entonces necesitamos materia prima
materia materia prima prima y por
supuesto necesitamos gente y hay dos
tipos de gente que necesitamos una que
esté realmente pues ya sabes
atornillando o lo que sea necesario y
presionando los botones es decir
necesitamos fuerza laboral le voy a
poner asigna más labor labor por un lado
y por otro lado alguien que tenga idea
después a qué se dedica la fábrica área
que esté dirigiendo y organizando y que
tenga idea de hacia dónde va el proyecto
entonces también necesitamos
organización organización y acá entra la
administración y entran otro tipo de
personas vale bueno entonces aquí cuando
logramos juntar todos estos objetos del
terreno
y dio las herramientas y lo que sea
déjame contarlos todos voy a ponerle así
este lo pasamos para acá lo pasamos para
acá entonces vamos a juntar todos estos
elementos y cuando los juntamos con un
poco de suerte y pues si todo marcha
bien entonces de aquí obtenemos una
cierta producción una producción
producción muy bien y esto es ya como
que el resultado de todo nuestro trabajo
pero ve o sea aquí tenemos varios
elementos sin embargo en la teoría
clásica estos dos de acá el edificio y
las herramientas de equipo se les
conocen como capital están separados de
todos los demás y se los piensa se les
piensa como capital lo voy a poner aquí
capital
a vital algo así y entonces por qué se
les separan pues porque son cosas hechas
por los humanos fabricadas por los
humanos con el propósito específico de
que con eso se pueda fabricar otras
cosas por ejemplo el edificio la fábrica
sirve para que pues para que se puedan
hacer aviones acá y las herramientas
aquí sirven para darle la forma a las
espadas a los escudos o lo que sea
entonces son cosas pensadas
específicamente y hechas específicamente
para realizar otras cosas no sé por
ejemplo sea un sombrero un sombrero aquí
voy a pintar un sombrero más o menos
algo así sea un sombrero también es algo
que es fabricado por los humanos le voy
a poner un adorno también es algo que es
fabricado por los humanos sin embargo su
objetivo principal no es la producción
de otras cosas sino su objetivo
principal es la moda o es tener una
mejor calidad de vida tapándose del sol
vaya o sea el sombrero no está hecho
específicamente para producir otro
objeto entonces esto no sería capital
a diferencia del edificio y de las
herramientas que sirven para fabricar
otra cosa más entonces esto es como que
en el sentido en el sentir
clásicos y sin embargo con focal con el
paso del tiempo como que se empezó a
hablar de otro tipo de capital y ya no
sólo se hablaba del capital en este
sentido de acá sino que empezaron a
salir varios tipos de capitales por
ejemplo se empezó a hablar acerca del
capital humano lo voy a poner por acá
por acá capital
capital humano humano también se empezó
a hablar acerca del capital financiero
capi
capital financiero financiero
y bueno o sea justamente surgieron estos
nuevos términos en analogía con este
término clásico de capital entonces a
qué se refiere esto de capital humano y
de capital financiero pues por ejemplo
en el caso del capital humano no es
simplemente labor o sea no es únicamente
la gente que está trabajando sino que el
capital humano contempla la preparación
de esa gente es decir son inversiones
que se realizan en las personas para
poder producir más es decir con el fin
específico de producir entonces a lo
mejor pues a una persona se le puede dar
su pago pero eso no sería capital humano
porque no estás como que invirtiendo en
esa persona para que produzca más
soporte para que tenga una mejor
producción más bien que sería pues esto
del capital humano serían cosas como por
ejemplo nuevas habilidades habilidades
nuevos talentos talentos la preparación
preparación
entrenamiento entrenamiento
miento ok entonces son como ciertos
objetos o ciertos ciertas cosas un poco
abstractas pero pero que se invierten
para que haya mayor producción o sea no
simplemente es pedirle a la persona que
mueva una tabla de un lugar a otro que
esté presionando los botones que es lo
que sería el labor sino que son
inversiones que se realizan adicionales
para que las personas puedan hacer más
para que puedan tener una mejor
producción y para que puedan hacer cosas
más interesantes de modo similar el
capital financiero también pues tiene
que ver con dinero entonces por un lado
tenemos el efectivo
pensémoslo así y el efectivo se puede
utilizar para muchas cosas verdad el
efectivo se puede utilizar para comprar
sombreros o para ir al cine pero el
capital financiero está pensado
específicamente está pensado
específicamente para realizar
actividades de un negocio para que se
produzca más entonces dentro del capital
financiero pues podemos pensar en el
capital de trabajo específicamente ahora
si lo que se le paga a los obreros es el
efectivo
que se utiliza para apagar o bien
podemos pensar en el dinero que se
utiliza para realizar inversiones
entonces podemos pensar en el dinero que
necesitamos para comprar este edificio y
estas herramientas es decir el dinero el
efectivo que se usa para comprar capital
y en el sentido clásico bueno entonces
nada más quería en este vídeo platicar
un poco de estas cosas que necesitamos
para producir y pues tocar este tema del
capital que es fundamental para el
capitalismo y bueno quería verlo desde
dos puntos de vista desde el punto de
vista clásico que nada más son objetos y
desde estas nuevas corrientes modernas
que contempla en capital humano capital
financiero y otros tipos de capital